Whether you're going for bling, swagger, or
just looking for a different way to decorate,
you might be surprised at what you can do
with the tabs from your soda cans. In this
project we're up-cycling these marvels of
engineering, into lightweight aluminum chains.
For this project, I swung by a local recycling
depot, and picked a whole load of soda can
tabs, for free. Now let's get started by breaking
off the rivet mounts for each of the tabs
we want to use, then stack five of them together
so they're all aligned. This will be the first
link in our chain, and you can see I turned
the smooth shiny surfaces so they're facing
outward. Now if we take a pair of scissors
and carefully cut a slit through the thinner
end, this gives us the ability to gently pry
it open, creating a small gap. Now all you
have to do is push the hook through the thicker
end of our chain link, and bend the metal
back to close the gap. It's as easy as that.
Just repeat the process again until you've
got 5 tabs secured in place, and double check
the sides to make sure they're smooth. If
you want a longer chain, just continue the
process by cutting 5 tabs at a time, and linking
them on to the end. Once you get the hang
of it, there's so much you can do with the
idea. For example, you could try making yourself
a custom key chain, or maybe even a wallet
chain. That's pretty awesome. How about a
metallic wrist band like this? You can see
I linked the chain to itself so the piece
is completely seamless. Now because our chain
is aluminum, it's amazingly lightweight, but
still strong enough to replace my belt. How's
that for swagger? If you're feeling especially
adventurous, try closing your chain off with
a padlock and throwing it around your neck.
I ended up using this one as a picture frame,
and I bet you could use the same idea for
framing a license plate as well. By the way,
make sure you hang onto your colored tabs.
They can add a lot of variety to pump up your
style. Well now you know how to engineer these
common soda tabs, into lightweight metallic
chains. Now what they're used for is completely
up to you. That's it for now. If you liked
this project, perhaps you'll like some of
my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com